I want to clarify some of the
terminology I used in the last video but
before I do that let's just make sure
that we understand the mechanism of how
arteries can get blocked so in the last
video we talked about these plaques
forming and if this plaque is unstable
at some point it could rupture and when
it ruptures this material can start to
flow out into the bloodstream it can
start to float into the bloodstream and
two things will happen I just want to
make it a little bit more clear relative
to the last video especially now that I
can zoom in on these arteries two things
can happen Plex or I should say clotting
not plaques these are the plaques that
have been released the clotting the
clotting factors can kind of clot these
released these released pieces from the
plaque and the other thing that can and
often will happen and I didn't talk
about this in depth in the last video is
that you can also have when this thing
ruptures you can also have blood clots
blood clots form here let me do this in
a red more reddish color so you can also
have blood flop clots form on the
ruptured plaque so everything even if
the the plaque the part of the plaque
that has not begun to move can can
experience clotting and also the part of
the plaque that's kind of been dumped
into the blood stream can also clot and
the last video we saw that one of these
clots can go downstream to some point
where the arteries get narrow enough so
that they actually block the artery so
that they actually block the artery
right over here and that just restricts
the blood flow so now all of a sudden
you don't have any blood flow going
downstream and all of this muscle tissue
that needs the blood flow from this
point that needs to get oxygen from that
it might die and you might have a
myocardial infarction or a heart attack
now what I want to clarify is the actual
terminology I somewhat and it was a
little bit I guess I was a little bit
hand-wavy with the terminology we only
get a little bit deeper here this actual
clot that forms that can restrict the
blood vessel this is a this right here
is a thrombus this right here is a
thrombus thrombosis
the process of a thrombus forming so
thrombosis is are these blood clots that
form that can actually help to kind of
obstruct obstruct a blood vessel so this
thrombus right here is actually going to
make it harder for the blood to flow
through it's going to make it harder for
the blood to flow through this vessel
now any of these released pieces or
chunks in any of these blood vessels
that can float around and eventually
lodge themselves in and eventually block
block the blood flow these are called
emboli or if I if I just use them in the
singular one of these is an embolus is
an embolus and I want to be clear an
embolus is the general term for anything
that can float around in your blood and
eventually lodge itself at some point in
in in your in your circulatory system
and restrict the blood flow what we drew
in the last video and in particular this
one as well is that these emboli that
have that are also clotted so they're
also kind of thrombus that they're also
thrombi and emboli at the same time
these this right here would be called a
thromboembolic thromboembolic thrombo
embolus embolus these words are strange
to say sometimes so it wouldn't be wrong
to call it an embolus but in particular
we say it's a thromboembolic soon oh
that it's kind of this clotted material
around this released plaque that can go
Lodge itself and the last video I call
this a thrombosis but that was really
not quite right the thrombosis is really
the formation of the clot that can
restrict the blood flow when it actually
lodges itself further when it actually
breaks off becomes an embolus and lodges
itself further off and restricts
restricts blood flow this is called a
thromboembolism thromboembolism let me
write this the Rhambo embolism so
hopefully I'm not confusing you too much
at these medical terms confuse me a lot
but I want to make it very clear that
our most this is just the general
formation of a blood clot inside of a
blood vessel that can restrict the flow
of blood so this right here this this is
thrombosis occurring that is thrombosis
thrombosis once things break off and
they start floating around there an
ambulance that's the general term for it
and in particular if it's if it's broken
off material that is due to a clot it's
a thrombo ambulance
so thrombo ambulances are a more
specific way of calling it an embolus
and once one of these things lodge
themselves and block and block the blood
flow that's a thrombo embolism you could
also call that an embolism just when you
say it's thromboembolism it makes it a
little bit more specific to know that
it's kind of clotted material so
hopefully that doesn't that clarifies
things and doesn't confuse you too much